Star Wars has been a force in pop culture
for nearly 40 years in just about every kind
of medium imaginable.
Thanks to movies, TV shows, books, and comics,
fans have plenty of materials to follow their
favorite characters.
With all the stories out there, some of the
more imaginative fans have conjured up some
wild theories about the galaxy far, far away.
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 Movie Theories
That Completely Change Star Wars Films.
Darth Jar-Jar
Jar-Jar Binks is perhaps the most reviled
character in the saga, but does he deserve
more respect than he gets?
Some – probably jokingly – have theorized
that Jar-Jar is the evil mastermind behind
everything that happens in the movies, using
his outward appearance as a ruse to mislead
those around him – similar to Yoda in Empire
Strikes Back.
Apparently, Jar-Jar was a co-conspirator with
Palpatine and manipulated events so that the
Sith rose to power and took over the galaxy.
This is amusing to consider, but there’s
no way we’ll know for sure.
Jar-Jar will never be heard from again.
Supreme Leader Plagueis
All Star Wars fans are trying to figure out
the true identity of Supreme Leader Snoke,
one of the new villains shown in The Force
Awakens.
The most popular belief is that Snoke is actually
Darth Plagueis, the Sith Master who taught
Palpatine the ways of the Dark Side.
Palpatine mentioned in Episode 3 that Plagueis
had the ability to create life and cheat death,
so even if Plagueis was “killed” by Palpatine,
he could still possibly return.
And Snoke’s scarred physical appearance
indicates that he’s been through a lot,
perhaps injuries from Palpatine’s betrayal
all those years ago.
The answers should be coming soon.
Rey Skywalker
Moviegoers don’t learn the parentage of
Force Awakens protagonist Rey, so all the
theories popularized before the film’s release
still hold water.
The most prevalent is that she is the child
of Luke Skywalker, keeping in line with the
idea that the saga is the Skywalker family
story.
In Episode 7, Rey is shown to be adept at
flying, and she picks up on her Force abilities
rather quickly.
This is similar to some of the other Skywalkers
shown in the film, Luke and Anakin.
And besides, Rey seems too important for her
parents to be “nobody,” right?
Palpatine is the Father
All we know about Anakin’s birth is that
there apparently was no father, and it was
a miracle.
As the prequel trilogy progresses, George
Lucas sheds a little more light on the concept.
When telling Anakin the story of Plagueis,
Palpatine mentions that Plagueis could use
the Force to influence midi-chlorians and
create life.
His facial expression when making that revelation
implies that Palpatine learned this trick
from his master, and for some reason decided
to give life to Anakin.
Things are still muddy, but this is a little
better than Anakin just showing up out of
nowhere and it gives the series another layer
of intrigue.
Boba Fett Killed Luke’s Family
Obi-Wan mentions that Imperial stormtroopers
are precise with their shots, but Star Wars
fans are well aware that isn’t the case.
It’s believed that stormtroopers are the
ones who kill Uncle Owen and Aunt Beru when
looking for the droids, but the execution
doesn’t line up with the ineptitude that’s
on display throughout the series.
Who could have done it?
Boba Fett.
Not only was the bounty hunter on Tatooine
during the film’s events, in Empire, Vader
specifically instructs him to not disintegrate
his prey.
Perhaps Vader contacted the bounty hunter
and put him on the job.
Luke’s Hiding Place
It doesn’t make sense that Obi-Wan would
hide Luke on Tatooine, which was also Vader’s
home planet.
But a theory proposes there’s a method to
Kenobi’s madness – Tatooine was the last
place Anakin would look for his son.
Anakin had several bad memories on the planet,
including watching his mother die.
Not only that, Episode II unfortunately shares
Anakin’s not-so-fond thoughts about sand,
which Tatooine is full of.
Looking to distance himself from his prior
life, Vader may not have even considered Tatooine
due to a desire to forget about the world
entirely as he learns about the Dark Side.
It makes sense, from a certain point of view.
Han Solo: Jedi Knight?
When Han first meets Luke and Obi-Wan, he
makes it clear he doesn’t believe in the
Force and mocks the “hokey religion.”
But what if he subconsciously could access
its power?
Some fans think Han is secretly Force sensitive,
since many of his actions in the original
trilogy – like flying through an asteroid
field – seem a little too fortunate to just
be good luck.
Plus, when Han dismisses the Force, Obi-Wan
makes a smug expression, hinting that he may
sense something in the smuggler.
If only Han had realized his full potential,
the Galactic Civil War could have ended much
sooner.
Chewie and R2: Rebel Spies
What if two side characters were working together
to ensure everything fell into place?
One theory suggests that Chewie and R2-D2
were Rebel spies, solving some of the plot
holes their inclusion in the prequels creates.
In Episode 3, Chewie is seen fighting alongside
with Yoda, who later would ask him to go to
Tatooine to look after Luke.
That explains why Chewie conveniently bumps
into Obi-Wan at Mos Eisley when he’s looking
for a ride off planet.
As for R2?
He convinced the Republic to not wipe his
memory so they’d still have access to his
intel.
He just kept that fact from C-3PO.
Qui-Gon, Lord of the Sith
Qui-Gon Jinn is shown to be a Jedi Master,
but perhaps he had some nefarious plans.
Some fans think he was a Sith in disguise
and plotted to overthrow the Jedi.
Qui-Gon is a maverick, who typically defies
the Jedi Council’s recommendations.
This extends to his feelings on young Anakin,
who he pushes to be trained despite concerns
about the fear and anger Anakin’s feeling.
Knowing that the boy was too old to begin
training, Qui-Gon thought that Anakin could
grow powerful with the Dark Side and throw
the Jedi into chaos.
It’s interesting, but it seems pretty diabolical
when Qui-Gon could just turn to the Dark Side.
Tarkin Is Snoke?!
Everyone has a theory about who Snoke is,
and we have a wild one of our own.
Could Snoke be Tarkin?
It's a stretch, but there's evidence to support
it.
Snoke has extensive knowledge of the rise
and fall of the Galactic Empire, Palpatine
and Vader.
In addition, he's never a confirmed Force
user, despite being Kylo Ren's master.
If Snoke was an ancient Sith or powerful Force
user, shouldn't Kylo be able to control it
better?
Time will tell if we're right, but it's a
fun thought for now until we learn more.
Check out more on this theory by clicking
on the link at the top right!
Thanks so much for watching!
Make sure you check out Danger Dolan’s new
video entitled “8 Creepiest Secrets In Kids
Films”.
He found some very interesting information
about the movies you grew up with so click
on the link and enjoy!
While you’re there make sure to subscribe
to the channel!
Those were our picks for the craziest Star
Wars fan theories.
Are there any we missed?
Which ones are your favorites?
Sound off in the comments section below! and
be sure to subscribe to our channel for more
fun videos like this one!